hello my name is dr benjamin
i'm an assistant professor of medical
oncology at the huntsman cancer
institute at the university of utah
i specifically focus on genitou urinary
malignancies
um i i put up this title slide uh so
that you can see our beautiful campus
here in the fall time of the year that
that we've just gotten into
um i'm always welcome to uh
uh visit with any of you and and uh
give you a nice tour of our campus if
you're ever out this way
uh today we're going to be talking about
immunotherapy specifically for prostate
and renal cell carcinomas uh
and i should say specifically prostate
adenocarcinoma and clear cell renal
carcinoma
and i've titled a panoply of futuristic
therapies because i'm going to be
starting with
where where we are today and then give a
slight glimpse at the end about
some interesting uh developments that
that
we're heading with in terms of research
so here's my conflicts of interest slide
um
i i'm a advisor and a consultant to a
number of companies as you can see here
and i've also received funding to do
or investigator it or investigate or
sponsor clinical trials from
excel access bavarian nordic clovis and
bristol-myers squibb
and and some of these companies do so
like bms for instance
uh cells immune therapy drugs that we'll
be talking about
today as well as exolexis
um so a couple of the learning
objectives that i hope to accomplish
today in our brief time together
is to understand the optimal first line
therapies for patients with metastatic
clear cell
renal carcinoma understanding the impact
of cancer vaccines in the treatment of
metastatic
testosterone suppression resistant
prostate cancer also called metastatic
castration resistant prostate cancer
and also to find the optimal patient
likely to
benefit from one of these prostate
cancer vaccines uh prevention
so theoretically speaking that's that's
what this slide is
is discussing what are the
characteristics of an ideal immune
therapy well first of all it's going to
have a high response rate
second is going to have very durable
responses and ideally
it that will also mean that it can cure
patients even with metastatic disease or
actually be able to cure even some
patients with metastatic disease
third it has to be tolerable across a
broad range of patients
such as those patients have renal
impairment hepatic impairment or perhaps
even the elderly
and finally it needs to be affordable so
some of the immune therapies that we
have today
meet some a number of these criteria
although it can be argued
not necessarily all of them but but
these are the characteristics of ideal
immune therapy we're going to come back
to a couple of these components um
as we go along
oh i think there we go uh so so
and this this then would be
characterizing some of those components
into a model if if we can
schematically diagram it of an ideal
immune therapy
as you can see very few patients have
primary progressive disease
to the treatment and and the response
lasts for a very long time and perhaps
is
even you can see this we call tell of
the curve and it leads to a cure
again robustly over a long time no this
is a progression free survival curve in
an overall survival curve
and so with that in mind let's talk a
little bit
about some immune therapies in the
context of renal cell carcinoma
so the the um idea i don't show any of
the data here but the idea of the
efficacy of immune therapy really
predated a a lot of these trials that
that we're going to be discussing today
and it started in the cytokine era with
high dose io2 and interferon
the majority of those patients did not
benefit from from the treatment but but
there was a small proportion of patients
who were about five to maybe 10 percent
of patients
that would be cured with that treatment
but but for the other 90 percent they
really derived no benefit from the
treatment at all
and but that really demonstrated that
immune therapy can work for kidney
cancer
and so lots of research uh
later uh we have the checkpoint
inhibitors
and so the the first trial that really
demonstrated the value of these
checkpoint inhibitors
was with the checkmate o25 trial which
was evaluating the volmab in the second
line treatment
so in this clinical trial navolmab at
three migs per keg was compared against
ephrolimus
as second line therapy in it enrolled
patients from 2012
through 2014 and and there was quite a
healthy number of patients that were
randomized um the minimum follow-up at
this initial
uh presentation that's what i'm showing
you here was only 14 months and the
primary
endpoint was overall survival and so as
you can see from the overall survival
curves it was better than ever a limas
with a hazard ratio of 0.73 and if you
look at the bottom
kaplan-meier curve the progression-free
survival
you can see that it does delay
progressions but
it it first of all
it doesn't have if you look at the
capillary curve there's a very steep
drop
off and so that very first criteria that
it benefits most patients we don't see
with with navol
monotherapy and secondly in terms of the
durable responses
there are some patients that have
durable responses but as you notice the
tail of the curve just
it's not really there just keeps
diminishing and dropping
and that that can be highlighted even
better with this longer term follow-up
the final follow-up this was presented
at geo asco earlier this year
and and as you can see even looking out
to this longer term period
uh again this this portion is
highlighted that the majority of
patients are not benefiting from the
ever-alignment therapy nor
the immune therapy most patients are
having primary disease progression as
their best response to treatment
but secondly if you look for this tell
the curve it never
really flatlines it just keeps dropping
and dropping and dropping
and so there are some patients even with
nivolumab monotherapy
that can have very long responses but
but i don't think
the data really supports that we are
curing anybody with
nivolumab monotherapy and the proportion
of patients that are having these really
durable robust responses
is arguably quite low
so that led to the development of
checkmate 214 which
is a combination immune therapy trial
the combination is ipolimab
a ctla4 inhibitor and nivolumab a
pd-1 inhibitor this was
the the primary endpoint but
specifically in the imdc intermediate
and poor risk patients although the
trial did enroll
favorable risk patients as well but the
primary endpoint was
was the responses seen in the
intermediate and poor risk patients
this trial compared the combination of
of nivolumab and ipalumumab
versus the standard of care at that time
of a tki which in this case they picked
sunitinib
it enrolled patients from 2014 through
2016
and the median the minimum follow-up was
30 months uh
and the co-primary endpoints were
overall survival and progression-free
survival
and as you can see from the top
kaplan-meier curve
there was a significant improvement in
overall survival with the combination
interestingly um we still see this
phenomenon if you look at the bottom
kepler marker that there's a significant
proportion of patients that have
primary disease progression is their
best response to therapy
notably though it's fewer patients
than with nivolumab monotherapy very
interestingly though if we look at the
tail of the curve it really does look
like we have a true tell of the curve
where patients are out multiple years
now and
they're not having any disease
progression so this combination does
appear
to result in significant uh
robust responses that arguably could be
potentially curative
and again i'm showing you not the
initial data from the new england
publication but if
if you'll notice if you look at the
x-axis the time this is the
long-term follow-up almost five years
out
that was published in lancet oncology
now specifically though if you look at
the favorable risk patients
there's no significant difference in
terms of overall survival or arguably
even with progression-free survival
between combination immune therapy with
epinevo
and pseudotimid tki monotherapy and
that's arguably
not arguably but that's really just due
to how well these patients do
overall just based on the biology of the
disease and you can see that in terms of
the media and overall survival
hasn't been reached for either arm yet
these patients do really well with
no matter what you give them
and and you can see very few patients
don't respond to any of these therapies
but but also interestingly
um the tail of the curve is not
particularly higher
in the favorable risk group compared to
the intermediate and porous group
but but it's still there the next first
line trial
is is the keynote trial 426 which is the
combination of excitation and
pembrolizumab
i don't have a lot of mechanistic
studies in here just because of the
slides in here just because of the time
constraints but
the the hypothesis with this combination
is that exciting can introduce a lot of
uh
modifications to the immune system by by
altering
t effector cells um anti-regulatory
cells in the tumor microenvironment
and thereby creating a synergistic
action with with
a checkpoint inhibitors such as
pembrolizumab apd
uh one axis inhibitor so in this
clinical trial the combination was
tested against
uh again the the standard first line
therapy at the time sunitanib
at the same doses in the checkmate 214
trial
patients were enrolled from october 2014
to 2016 very
very contemporaneously but almost
slightly delayed
compared to the checkmate trial about
the same number of patients were
randomized
uh the medium follow-up and at the time
of this reporting is shorter though than
than the follow-up we have a checkmate
214 medium follow-up was only 12.8
months
uh the co-primary endpoints are overall
survival and progression free survival
and notice this is in
all patients not just imdc intermediate
and porous patients
and as you can see from the overall
survival curve on the top
uh this combination was statistically
superior
to synthetic monotherapy with a hazard
ratio of 0.53
the progression-free survival was also
significantly improved compared to
sunitin and bono therapy
notice we don't see a tail of the curve
but there's also a very small number of
patients that have primary disease
progression as their best response to
therapy
um and in this last era it's just
highlighting that again
based on this short follow-up we have
this combination
we're not really seeing a tell the curve
but but i will
um uh put out one caution that if you
look at the median it's
uh progression free survival it hasn't
been
reached yet uh well i mean it's just
barely at that point
and so there there just might not be
enough follow-up to really see the tail
of the curve yet just because the
response rates are so high with this
combination
if we look at the subgroup analysis of
the keynote 426
trial based on clinical factors
including the imdc risk category
all the patients seem to benefit from
this treatment including the favorable
risk patients
they seem to benefit with the
combination over signified loan
so that is one distinct difference from
this combination versus the
checkmate 214 trial and then finally
the 9er trial was just published
this error presented i should say at
esmo just a few weeks ago and this is
looking at the combination of caboxantin
and benevolemab versus again the same
standard first line therapy
of sunitanim what i'm not showing you is
the data of exetinib
plus a value map and that's simply
because of time constraints and and that
trial does not have an overall survival
advantage compared to
the exatinibian pembrolis map um so i'm
just
highlighting some key unique studies so
that that i'll show improved overall
survival compared to synthetic
so anyway back to the 90r trial uh so
again the same
all of these trials have have the same
control arms pseudonym same dosing same
schedule
651 patients were randomized a medium
follow-up of 18.1 months and the primary
endpoint is radiographic
progression-free survival
so if you look in the the top curve i've
i've switched them a little bit so now
pfs is in the top kaplan mic curve
simply because that's the primary
endpoint
it's significantly improved progression
free survival compared to synthetic with
a hazard ratio of 0.51
the second a key secondary endpoint was
overall survival and it also
significantly
improved survival compared to synthetic
with a hazard ratio of 0.6
if you look at the beginning of the
curves there's
very few patients that have primary
disease progression in fact
nobody had primary disease progression
in this trial
in the combination arm if you look at
the tail of the
curve it's it's with the short follow-up
it's hard to say
because once you finally start getting
to 18 months there's so
few patients uh that are still in
follow-up that it's
difficult to say if we're really seeing
a tail of the curve or not but
if you look from that 15 to almost 21
months
it does look like maybe we're starting
to see a tail of the curve happen
so perhaps this combination cavazantinib
just is the right tki to partner with
with uh checkpoint inhibitors to to
truly result in high response rates
uh good tolerability and and um
durable responses um that being said
that the follow-up isn't quite there yet
uh for for me to feel comfortable saying
for sure it leads to a lot of these
durable responses
but the the kaplan-meier curve looks
intriguing
and provocative in that regard regarding
subgroup analysis
in the favorable risk group
so there did not seem to be any
difference
based on imdc prognostic groups so the
favorable
risk patients benefited more than
sunitanib
as well as the imdc intermediate and
poorest groups
and that is true regarding
progression-free survival as well as
overall survival
so how do i treat patients with
metastatic rcc in the first line setting
well for the imdc intermediate porous
patients i prefer to use ipolimumab and
the volmab simply because of the
long-term data
demonstrating a clear durable response
and perhaps cure
for for a proportion of these patients
however for those patients with
rapidly progressive disease i tend to
start with the tki based therapy just
because there can be this delayed
response to the intermediate or two to
epinevo
as well as there is that proportion of
patients that don't benefit
for the favorable risk group uh right
now my preferred therapy based on the
data
would be exciting and pembrolizmab
however
cambodian navolumab is likely an option
although it's not yet approved
um but it is important to highlight that
any of these three combinations
of well when when assuming the 90-hour
trial
or combination gets approved but any of
these combinations are acceptable and
appropriate and it's really important to
remember
that all of this just highlights the the
fundamental
key point that any combination is
preferred
over single agent therapy except in rare
circumstances
uh and and one of those circumstances
perhaps could be someone that has
significant active autoimmune disease
so what is the future of immune therapy
and renal cell carcinoma
uh well there's there's a number of
interesting developments that are
happening for instance in the cosmic 313
trial
this is a phase three study that's
estimated to have almost 700 patients
and it's looking at the triple
combination of cabozantinib
plus nivolumab and implement versus
a standard of care of ipolimab versus
nivolumab
this is to see if the campus antenna
really adds any more synergy
to the epinevo combination and this is a
first line trial
there's also the contact 3 trial which
is a phase 3 trial
estimated to have about 500 patients and
is looking at cabozantinib and a
teasalismab versus campoxantinid
specifically in the second line setting
after patients have already failed some
other immune therapy there is some
some data to suggest that this
particular combination can salvage
responses
even in those patients whose tumor has
become resistant to
pd-1 axis inhibitors in the past
and there's a number of other um
and those are really in the metastatic
setting but
but there's a lot of very interesting
studies in the adjuvant and neoadjuvant
setting
we await a whole slew of trials looking
at monotherapy
in the adjuvant setting with checkpoint
inhibitors obviously all the tki studies
were
largely negative um but there's there's
a very interesting study looking at
uh nivolumab in the neoadjuvant setting
neoadjuvant plus adjuvant setting and we
this is still enrolling and we actively
wait the results
and then there's also checkmate 914
which is looking at
multiple combinations of nivolumab
versus epinephone evo versus placebo
in the adjuvant setting this is also a
phase 2 trial so all of these checkpoint
inhibitors are really starting to be
tested earlier on in the disease process
in the high risk localized setting then
there's also some novel combinations in
the metastatic setting such as the pivot
09 trial
which is really bringing back some of
this
older data from the cytokine era looking
at
pegulated interleukin-2 plus nivolumab
versus the physician's choice of tki
there's sunitene or caboz antonym so
there's a lot of very fascinating
develop
developments happening in the renal cell
carcinoma space
so now let's pivot and and in the last
few minutes talk about
immune therapy and prostate cancer so
does immune therapy work in prostate
cancer
so prevenge was the first immune therapy
tested in a phase
iii clinical trial to show benefit in
prostate cancer it's a dendritic vaccine
stimulating apc
androgen presenting cell recognition of
prostatic acid phosphatase or pap
it was first tested in 2006 and the
approval came in 2010
because the results were unclear
in that first trial and so a couple of
other subsequent confirmatory trials had
to be conducted
and so that's why the the delay was was
quite significant
so far there's no other approved immune
therapy trials with the caveat of those
patients that
in a tissue agnostic way fit the
criteria for pembrolisma
so here's the dilemma of vaccine
therapies now these are two of those
trials the d9902a
is that first trial in 2006 and then
impact
in 2010 is is one of those confirmatory
trials
the the publications don't have nice
graphs for me to put up here so i
for all of these things so so you can
see i just put some text in
in those cases where it's not but if you
look at the psa response rate
it's very low so like two five percent
right so the majority of patients are
not
really seeming to benefit from this
treatment
at least in terms of that measure
in terms of progression free survival
again we see this same
excuse let me go back we see that same
steep drop of the curve where the
majority of patients are
having disease progression as their best
response to therapy
and that's true for both of these
studies but intriguingly and
oddly there is an improvement in overall
survival
so how can you have an improvement in
pfs there how can you have no
improvement in pfs but still an
improvement in overall survival
and and looking at a
sort of model of this i think really
helps me understand it
so if you look at the green line green
line and this is just some arbitrary
cancer volume that's required to be
achieved
to have someone die from from cancer
related problems
if you look at the blue line again this
is a simplistic model
but let's assume that the cancer just
grows in a linear fashion and so over
some period of time whatever that time
is
the the cancer will grow sufficiently
for that person to die
um the data to me suggests the how
provenge works is it doesn't
cause tumor death per se in terms of
gross tumor volume
but it does delay the growth curve it
slows it down
and so and and so because you get this
decrement in tumor velocity
then you can have no improvement in
progression-free survival but yet you
can have this
overall survival advantage
so are there molecular predictors of
response of whose cancers are going to
benefit
more versus another um and so if
if you it has been tested you know from
from those three clinical trials
molecular characteristics were evaluated
um and and there are some that do
suggest
uh patients are more likely to benefit
um if you look at androgen presenting
cell activation that didn't seem to make
a difference between
those that did have a better response
and versus those that did not
if you look at other things
like the antigen itself expression um
pa 2024 which is this fusion protein
of prostatic acid phosphatase plus gmcsf
you do see that those patients that
whose tumor expresses it more
have a better response to this therapy
although it is important to know that
none of these things are clinically
testable today and this is just all
research-based findings and and so
in terms of molecular predictors no
there's nothing in clinical practice
that we can use today to help guide
who may or may not be responding or
could respond to to
this vaccine are there clinical
predictors of response
so ucsf uh evaluated
94 consecutive patients realizing this
is a retrospective
analysis they identified 114 and
excluded 20 for a few various reasons
and this was done from 2010 through 2016
with a reasonable
follow-up of two years the majority of
their patients had
eco zero a healthy proportion had low
gleason scores
and all had relative most of them had a
relatively
low psa but did have a quite fast psa
doubling time
um if you look at the median overall
survival
in terms of e-cog status which is the
one on the left
the majority of patients are the the
patients that did better
were those patients that had an e-cog of
zero
also if you look at the psa doubling
time
the patients who had a slower
psa doubling time tended to benefit
longer which
based on that model makes sense because
if
prevent decreases the rate by say this
is an arbitrary number
but say if it cuts it by 50 percent if
your tumor growth rate is already very
fast then changing that 50 percent
doesn't change a lot but if it's growing
relatively slowly
decreasing that by 50 makes a huge
difference in terms of the time
uh benefit the patients see and finally
earlier seems to be better um as seen in
in the kaplan curve number c
those patients that had not yet received
abiorenza
did better compared to those that had
abirenza i don't think there's any data
to suggest that there's an interaction
between the vaccine and abiorenza
i think it just has to do with the
patients are earlier on in their disease
process
and so there's more time to benefit from
this
decrease in tumor growth velocity
and finally there's the prostate vaccine
this is a cancer vaccine with psa
as the tumor-associated antigen and
therefore it stimulates diesel activity
it uses this dual prime boost
idea and it in addition has
co-stimulatory molecules on it three
co-stimulatory molecules that are
designed to prime and stimulate the
immune system in general
but as you can see there was absolutely
no difference between in this large
phase
iii trial of 1200 patients or i say over
1200 patients there's no difference
in in the overall survival between any
of these arms any of these three arms
whether the patients receive vaccine
or vaccine plus gmc asf or the placebo
arm
there's there's a lot of i guess i
should go back here and say there's a
lot of
ideas and hypotheses about why this
vaccine didn't work including maybe now
that it's being tested later there's
just so many more potent therapies
that mild benefit that we see with
vaccines is sort of
masked now and and not evident but be
that as it may
no one knows exactly sure why it didn't
work maybe it's just not a potent enough
vaccine or it's the wrong antigen
but it but it didn't work um what about
checkpoint inhibitors
so the pembrolizumab monotherapy
keynote 199 um in in prostate cancer has
a couple of different cohorts
um so in cohort one it's pdl one
positive
in cohort two it's pdl one negative and
cohort three is pdl1 positive or
negative but they have bone only disease
right so they don't have recess
measurable lesions right they don't have
soft tissue disease that you can
measure and evaluate for a change in
size on ct scans
but cohorts one and two had to have
recess measurable disease
so this enrolled patients from 2016
through 2017
and a reasonable number of patients were
enrolled
across the three cohorts you can see the
n uh for each of those columns in the
very top
you look at the waterfall plots in terms
of overall response rates there are some
patients that have huge responses to
these therapies
but it's very minimal and if you look at
these three different colors between
cohorts one
two and three there does not seem to be
a consistent theme about pdl1 predicting
response to this
treatment or not if you look at the
table on the right
you can see that a very small proportion
of patients have an
objective response rate whether it's in
the pdl one positive
negative or bone predominant
the bone predominant doesn't have
objective response rates right because
you can't measure it but if you look at
psa responses again
fairly low in the one to five percent
range
um so what about few so right now
there's no
fda approval for checkpoint inhibitors
and prostate cancer except for those
patients that have
msi unstable disease uh and and
pembrolizumab has a tissue agnostic
indication for that
which coincidentally is only about two
roughly two maybe five percent but
probably around two to three percent
of prostate adenocarcinoma um
so future therapies there's a clinical
trial going on cosmic o21 specifically
cohort six um
that looked at kevos antenna plus a
tesolizumab
in in testosterone suppression resistant
prostate cancer castration resistant
prostate cancer
and if you look at the baseline
demographics there's
you know a lot of patients have lymph
node and bone involvement but a
reasonable number also had visceral
disease like lung and liver that suggest
more aggressive
biology the a large proportion of these
patients had
dose taxal prior dose taxal therapy and
all of them had novel hormonal therapies
with abiorenza
if you look at the waterfall plots this
is strikingly different
than than pembrolizumab monotherapy the
majority of patients responded
there were a few com complete responses
but very few patients had primary
disease progression in fact in this
cohort only four of them
had primary disease progression and
primary disease progression is is
defined as greater than a 20 percent
rise
of your measurable lesions 20 to 30
is stable disease and anything below
that is partial or complete responses
if you look at the bar graph across the
bottom again pdl1 status did not seem to
predict
response
so in conclusion we see that immune
therapy
works for prostate cancer
we are just in the process uh with with
lots of research trying to figure out
how to make it work much better for
for prostate cancer so
getting back to to our objectives we
learned that immune therapy leads to
robust durable responses in patients
with metastatic clear cell renal
carcinoma
in combination there and combination
therapy is the recommended first line
treatment
the optimal first line combination
therapy is yet to be determined
due to the relatively short follow-up of
some of the
tki-based combinations such as
pembrolizumab
and exetenib and cabozantinib and evolna
and that short follow-up makes it
difficult really to compare with
uh the previous standard first line
combination of ipolium ab
and the volume cures are possible in
some patients with metastatic clear cell
renal carcinoma treated with combination
immune therapy
and there's even if patients aren't
cured there's a greater proportion that
do have durable responses
switching to prostate cancer
vaccine-based immune therapy is modestly
active in metastatic prostate cancer
and has a role in treating some patients
and potentially more potent active
immune therapy combinations are
currently under development in prostate
cancer and likely will be fda approved
in
in the near future and and the fda
approval
for pro bench
does not stipulate any specific
patient or disease characteristics
but perhaps these slower growing cancers
might be more
responsive or have a greater benefit
so thank you for your time and i'm
grateful for for all the patients that i
that i have the privilege to treat and
for
a number of funding agencies that help
me with my ongoing research
and i'm happy to discuss any questions
with you uh either
you know you can send me an email or you
can send me a
twitter my handle is listed below thank
you